hier sind wir qua stamme aus dem
saarland das ist richtig und der titel
ganz paris ist eine disco richtig genau
das unser team mit dem wir für das
saarland antreten ein disco chanson wie
man das so bezeichnen kann wir freuen
uns ich habe jetzt auch schon weil wir
gleich probe aber in meinen disco outfit
angezogen passt zum passt zum chanson
sensationell beherrschen denn her keine
ahnung dass geschneidert worden irgendwo
in colonia in köln wollen dem saarland
oder in hier ihnen im inland der mode
ich meine saarland ist ja deswegen
kostüm kunst colonia hammer hammer
hammer gut saarland warum seid ihr so
viele ich meine das kleinste bundesland
ist mit den meisten leuten auf der bühne
und das liegt sicherlich an unserer
musik wir machen also ein bisschen big
band sound auf hermann leeser sektion
dabei
das sind schon mal drei leute und dann
eine klassische line up von einer band
und normalerweise machen ein bisschen so
rockmusik popmusik und mit blazer
garniert und jetzt zu disco bisschen
funky passt das auch da braucht man
fachleute das
ok und der französische akzent jetzt mal
hand aufs herz ist der echt oder ist er
trainiert ich sag mal so mit der zeit
sehr früh ist wahrscheinlich gesprochen
wie derzeit ruft man sich da ein
bisschen so mit dem axa reim ich bin sag
ich mal so so deutsch wie sein darf und
so französisch wie ich sein muss um
einem ägypter für die neue mensa wie
großen glanz zu verleihen denn er
benötigt aber auch wenn wir hin und
wieder ein bisschen an der aktion
schraube drehen da ist schon einiges an
franzose in uns dann hast du das denn
gemerkt dass das ist ja mal eine der
stärken ist was die französische axa
oder ich sag mal so wie es mir in die
wiege gelegt worden aber gemerkt habe
ich das erste mal als ich 13 war denn da
bekam ich mein erstes kompliment
sagte die man marcel du kennt er kein
pardon und den axa hat sicherlich
irgendwie auch ein bisschen damit
gespielt okay gut glaubt er damit denn
gut anzukommen beim buvisoco wie stehen
ihre chancen ist natürlich immer die
ganz große frage ja also wir sind
newcomer vor allem in albanien newcomer
und deutschland sehr populär
ein bisschen und die konkurrenz ist sehr
sehr hart wir versuchen
vor allem eine gute show zu machen ich
weiß nicht wie viele fans wir
mobilisieren werden aber ich glaube
unser auftritt wird auch sehr sexy und
von daher vielleicht machen wir den
leuten ja ein bisschen bisschen freude
über den die platzierung kann ich nicht
sagen weil das ist ja schon ist es
richtig wenn ich das als sehr 80er mäßig
beschreibe oder ja ist schon 17 wir
haben wir haben wir haben auch alle
unsere wurzeln sollen in dieser zeit
70er 80er und das ist leider ein kleiner
kontrast ein musikalisch exotisch im
gegensatz zu vielen anderen chanson
solltet ihr dann ein bisschen mehr
singer songwriter sind haben wir da
stelle ich mir ein bisschen heraus und
vielleicht ist das ja ein vorteil für
uns wir werden sehen wenn ihr es wenn du
sagst ihr seid ein verwurzelt ich würde
mal behaupten ihr habt diese musik aller
nicht mehr bewusst erlebt na ja wir
haben sie immer live erlebt aber sie
nach nein also wir fühlen uns glaube ich
in den 80er 70er 80er musikalisch auch
sehr wohl auch wenn wir nicht jetzt ein
klassischer retro benzin sondern auch
moderne sachen machen aber gerade
speziell dieser titel der ist so ein
bisschen und den eltern unserer kinder
gewidmet okay
oder natürlich ich bin großer fan von
von prinz und
freut man sich noch ein bisschen funky
music machen kann super also wer diese
art von musik mag und vor allen dingen
das saarland unterstützen will und wer
per von dem verdienen
sensationell findet der gibt erstmal
diesem video fans ab favorisiertes und
und und und posten posten posten und
natürlich bei prosieben zu schauen und
anrufen für die jungs her auf jeden fall
wir sind sehr auf unterstützung
angewiesen
heutzutage haben einmal facebook hat man
immer profil wie man sehen andere bands
hatten über unter 1000 follower
da sind wir noch nicht aber wir hoffen
ein bisschen auch auf die zweitstimmen
dass jeder neben seinem eigentlichen
favoriten noch einen ein erzieherischer
murat und
vielleicht für uns wartet und dann
wollen wir mal weiter singen also
mindestens die zweitstimme
eigentlich hat sich pia august verdienen
aber dass ist wie weggelassen weil das
war mir immer schon ein bisschen
peinlich ich wusste da fehlt was
okay